منذ الليله وحتى هذه
اللحظه الغارات لم تتوقف على مخيم جباليا
وعلى جباليا البلد وعلى شمال القطاع القصف
عنيف
جدا احزمه ناريه متواصله دمار واسع شهداء
ومصابون في الطرقات لم تتمكن الطواقم
الطبيه من الوصول اليهم قذائف مدفعيه
متواصله على المنازل وعلى
الشوارع الوضع كارثي جدا لا يتوفر اي
مستشفيات او اي خدمات طبيه كل من يصاب
يستشهد كل من يصاب يستشهد الوضع صعب جدا
الاحتلال الان يحاول التقدم اكثر الى مخيم
جباليا والى جباليا البلد من خلال القصف
العنيف من قبل الطائرات الحربيه ومدفعيه
الاحتلال طبعا الاحتلال ايضا خلال هذا
القصف العنيف دمر عدد كبير من المنازل على
رؤوس ساكنيها لم نتمكن من الوصول لهذه
المناطق حتى اللحظه بسبب استمرار القصف
واطلاق ذف المدفعيه على هذه الاماكن بشكل
متواصل طبعا الان الوضع في الشمال كارثي
على الجانب الصحي وعلى الجانب الانساني
وعلى جانب الحصار الذي يفرضه الاحتلال
الان على جباليا وعلى مخيم جباليا الان
الامر يشتد اكثر الاحتلال يحاول السيطره
على البلد وعلى مخيم جباليا من جميع
المحاور من خلال تنفيذ احزمه ناريه واطلاق
قذائف مدفعيه في كل مكان حتى يمنع اي شخص
او اي مواطن من التنقل او التحرك من مكان
لاخر ورغم كل هذا ستبقى التغطيه مستمره من
شمال
غزه